yeah i think um you know
number one is you got to be dedicated
and want to offer the services and sell
the equipment this isn't a
something you saw off the parts shelf
and you sell and you're done with it
it's something that um you need to be
able to work closely with your growers
and and provide those services and teach
them and help them grow
in their operation and as their
operation grows and they get more
comfortable you start adopting more
technology so you've really got to be
dedicated to
really wanting to provide this service
number two with that dedication you need
to be able to be dedicated to training
and becoming knowledgeable and staying
up on the technology
you know as technology changes there's
always something new every year you have
to be dedicated to offering
you know or providing training to your
customers as well as getting training
from the corporate companies
and number three um
you know
just really
be there for your customer and want help
them want to grow and and you know be
smart and understand their operations
and depending on
the farm or the size of the farm or the
fields you know if it's a field with
a farm with a lot of regular shaped
fields maybe clutch control is the best
thing to put in so that you can save on
seat costs because you're getting so
much overlap maybe it's a field that's
really straight and long and that kind
of stuff maybe steering is better or
maybe it's uh yield monitoring is the
most important thing to start with so
that you can start getting a report card
on the management changes you're making
your operation uh how are they affecting
how effective are they and where do we
go next so you know just working with
your growers very closely
yeah so the blue delta dealer program is
something we started a few years ago and
it's really the best of the best it's
our elite precision ag dealers it's the
dealers that are dedicated uh to staying
up on the technology going to training
several times a year
they carry parts and service and stock
and inventory and they're just generally
dedicated to
precision ag and to
helping your operation get the most out
of the technology that you're investing
in
and we provide additional resources and
support to those dealers and get
additional discount
they get you know
in front in the line for service uh
phone calls coming in
um you know there's marketing
opportunities that are provided to them
at the other dealers or not so there's
ways that we promote their dealership as
being an elite precision farming
dealership and then they also get help
in the service side that that they're
kind of the front line for us